so I got fired from my job because of  the kombucha video what yeah [ __ ]  really I got fired from the call center  [ __ ] no after that I  yeah you [ __ ]  um  yeah [ __ ] you should have made that  stupid video then I wouldn't have got  [ __ ] canned [ __ ] y'all and GT Dave  you got me fired I had been working  there for three months and that's when I  got fired nice and what was their reason  well she brought me in and she was like  [ __ ] you're doing you can't be making  videos yeah basically she was like you  need to decide if you want to be a young  professional or if you want to be a meme  and I was like what the [ __ ] kind of  decision is that I should have been like  you're just jealous [ __ ] you're ugly  you're mad as hell you're ugly [ __ ]  you're mad yeah you're right I'm your  boss you're fired yeah you're mad  yeah stupid [ __ ] mad you're a l and  I'm a dub  me to my 60 year old boss named Cheryl  yeah you're just mad because I'm a  [ __ ] hot girl yeah